c'était le match des mal classés ce
dimanche 12 novembre le club de plaisir
les clés derniers du classement recevait
l'avant-dernier courbevie un match à
enjeu pour la suite de la saison de
préationale en première période les
Évinois ont du mal dans la construction
offensive et surtout dans l'animation
défensive le score à la pause 17 à 8
pour les visiteurs on a été absent sur
sur tous le domaines défensivement et
offensivement l'adversaire nous a posé
un problème défensive avec une
défense lance bien le match après on n
pas su répondre tactiquement
offensivement et défensivement à ce que
l'équipe adverse nous proposait donc ça
été compliqué par rapport à ça on s'est
pas adapté au retour des vestiaires
plaisir les clés tentent de revenir au
score mais n'arrivve pas à combler le
retard de la première période pire les
joueurs des hautes scènes continuent
d'accentuer leur avance le score final
est sans appel 32 à 21 face à une équipe
qui était classé juste devant nous je
m'attendais pas non plus à avoir ce ce
genre de partie c'est vrai que que là il
y a eu vraiment une différence de de
niveau entre courbe voie et nous qui a
été assez impressionnante c'est
compliqué un peu ce début de saison mais
voilà on travaille c'est un peu mieux
mais voilà il y a toujours des choses à
changer et on va pas arrêter de
travailler pour pour remonter et se
maintenir c'est le plus important après
ce résultat le club de plaisir d'clé bon
dernier du classement avec 5 points de
retard sur l'avant-dernier les joueurs
devront rebondir rapidement dans ce
championnat de pr national les ivinois
joueront le samedi 25 novembre à 20h30 à
domicile contre l'équipe de palzo les
premiers du classement un exploit serait
le
bienvenu